- go red - parama and welcome to Marvis
it's a really funny game basically one
guy's flawless as an alien and whoever
he kills becomes Z and let's go oh this
is scary
I never go don't approach me right now
if you hello hello hello there over
there great George Miller George George
it's me
Zachary stay away from me George don't
you think I heard something please come
back I can't leave this one first yeah
great I have a question for you
what do you have to do right now I mean
we gotta stick to God that what you were
you were you'd alien no I wasn't we but
we were old college buddies and like if
you a skipper oh yes I'm Jesus
- Roni Sarah they had too much fun
making up these name hey hey hey who are
you
I'm Vincent oh you must be - get up
Vincent Vincent I'm not sure I trust you
just swing on Vincent still just
preparing or okay yeah rekelen cry you
are a human look at us
what can I trust you or what cause I
don't say I don't want to go halfway
through I guess and then find out us
everyone Oh boys guys I can't go I don't
I think I've called it I think I caught
it I caught this alien in there okay I'm
just like you guys
okay your dad your dirty alien no I'm
not I just want to play with you guys
listen if you weren't an alien what
would you say like what is your your how
are you a human I love food and I love
love I am sorry why have you got a
tentacle that sounds like an alien of it
I just am so happy and I love everything
I love I love so many things and I love
everything okay how long's everything
just go ahead let's go and guess I'm
gonna go to my goal okay guys see you
later I wonder my goal kill I have well
what was that I'm not sure I'm not going
I tell you I'm gonna tell you guys how
much I love everything full of love I
think you should go away not him you
guys don't have guns stealing so go away
now just asking at a ricochet quit
stay away
listen I'm Gatsby you know me there's a
movie about me it's problem
look guys there's conflicts I love food
so much hey hey stop killing my
ancestors no no see that was red I was
trying to forget how to clean
ken does what he naturally does a bass
no no oh we have a breach we have an
alien breach I don't know it could be
anyone and I follow me okay I trust you
now I forgot to secure the code what I
think it's isn't it one three three
seven because we're so amazing hahaha
wait are you an alien
only an alien would think of it hello
just like that nope it's don't worry uh
sorry what's your name my Leona yeah
three kids
Leona Pete's Leona it's pew Dona okay
thanks thanks for that okay don't worry
that could be anywhere
hey could be you they could be me
I need you or me okay they're probably
not you and me
but they could be that's it stop talking
Ana so where do you eat it let's go and
shower together Hannah come on we're
both we're both women right let's go to
the shower science just came out where
we were 30 seconds
go that place was really dirty let's go
and take a shower oh I each got eight so
no no no no I believe we have to take a
shower prioritise the iron apiece I'm
gonna leave you behind
okay well remember if they smell weird
they're probably an alien and if they
have bad bad breath that I guess that
goes together completing mission oh nice
how do I complete missions I don't
really understand what I'm doing
you're missing out Anna dicks okay I'm
not an alien now what the hell just take
a shower I just decided just like really
like showers relate to it Anna you
should come to the showers I don't know
where they are you should come to the
showers should join us on a space
expedition be our friend Anna uh I was
chilly already Anna this is good I'm not
sure yeah
and Akbar alright first I've enjoyed the
first episode of more of us if you want
more let me know or leave a like and it
helps me out a lot I really appreciate
it it's subscribe to become abroad today
and I'll see you in the next one or
maybe I'm behind you
best night ever like